hey friends what's up
i thought i'd try a new intro today i'm
not sure how i feel about it
anyway we're going to be doing ios 15
we're going to be doing we're going to
be talking
what we're going to be talking about ios
15 today and i've been using my new
iphone 13 for quite a while now and i
just wanted to go over some of my
favorite features and honestly the
number one feature that is my absolute
favorite is when someone sends you like
a freaking handful of photos you click
one single button and all of those
photos are automatically downloaded into
your camera roll before that would drive
me absolutely insane that i would just
have people like look you're put this in
frame io dropbox this make me an icloud
link don't send me 500 pictures in one
eye message there's also an option that
you can now have it set up so that these
will automatically be downloaded into
your camera roll with the shared with
you shared with you shared to you shared
for you shared with you in that feature
shared with you why do i feel so silly
shared with you this also works with
links and it's been so helpful to have
this because my sister and i have been
working on setting up a new studio space
and we're constantly sending links back
and forth so just to be able to go in
and look at the links and look at photos
separately and automatically have this
stuff downloaded into my camera roll why
did it have to take until ios 15 for
this to be a feature i don't know but
i'm here for it and so excited that it
is finally a thing the next one that is
kind of cool is using facetime links
this will allow you to facetime with
anybody outside of the apple ecosystem
whether they're on an android phone a pc
on a mac it doesn't matter you freaking
send them this link they can join in on
your facetime call the only thing that
you can't do with this is use share play
which actually isn't even out yet at the
time of making this video but still the
fact that we can now extend outside of
the apple ecosystem and set a facetime
link is pretty cool focus modes now this
is something that i have not yet
actually kind of really dove into and
kind of set up but it is such a cool
feature because you can set up various
modes for if you're working or if you're
at home and it'll basically turn your
phone into
a completely different phone so you can
actually set this up so if i have do not
disturb on i can see the people that are
allowed to notify me when this do not
disturb is on you can also have it
change the applications on your home
screen so that you won't be distracted
if you're in work mode to go scroll on
tick tock like i probably would be so if
i do have this do not disturb on people
will also be notified that i don't want
to be disturbed and those set
notifications that i've allowed will
come through everything else nope
there's also some new updates to memoji
so you can update your avatar with 40
different outfit choices there's two
different eye colors there's new glasses
there's nine new stickers and there's
multi-colored headwear as well as new
accessibility options oh they even have
two different types of masks that you
can wear now
but here's the clothing like this is an
aggressive amount of clothing options
that you can choose from i can barely
figure out what to wear every single day
on my own body now i have to worry about
my memoji body do not disturb
oh the notification summary okay so this
is interesting earlier today i set up a
notification summary because tyler's
like man you gotta check this out it's
super cool normally notifications come
in one by one as they happen and it's
pretty aggressive and overwhelming
especially if you get a lot of
notifications or if you're on social
media but with notification summary you
can set it up to take all of those
notifications over the past couple of
hours and combine them all into one so
you get a summary most people will
probably set it up to be like once or
twice a day well i i did four of them i
set my first summary at 8 am so it's
like when i'm up awake after i've had my
coffee i'll get my summary from the
morning my second summer at 11 a.m my
third at two and my fourth at nine pm
right before i go to bed i feel like
that's pretty good like that's not bad
at all i do think that the instagram dms
and twitter dms and things like that
will automatically be pushed through
because those are kind of timely but
sort of the everyday updates of like
so-and-so liked your photo oh so-and-so
is sharing something on tik-tok with you
those will all be kind of grouped into
one little kind of section so you don't
have to be obsessively like
what's happening what's happening
this next thing is by far
well i was gonna say it's one of my
favorite but i also have said every
single feature has been my favorite live
text in your photos this is now making
your entire camera library searchable so
if there's text that is featured on a
menu like i can go in here and search
for grilled cheese and if i've ever
taken a picture of a menu that has
grilled cheese on it i can go back to
that very photo but i've also been using
it a lot like this let me show you let
me get a book or something
so if there's like a piece of text or
something
i go and i can take a picture of it and
you'll see that this automatically is
popping up and recognizing that that's
text
take a picture
this
is now selectable
look at this
this is the freaking future like that's
so
cool and so useful there's even been
things that i've had to do like on my
computer that i've taken a picture of my
freaking monitor and then selected it
because it's actually quicker to do that
than to copy and paste it on the
keyboard and then paste it on it's
honestly it's just the use cases for
this
are endless i've seen phone numbers that
i've needed to call i just take a
picture copy paste it into the phone app
make the call so this is another little
thing that i actually did not even know
about until tyler brought this to my
attention
5g preferred over wi-fi my internet at
home is
it's not good i have the best internet
that i possibly can and it still is not
as good as the 5g service that i get on
my phone so this is kind of cool because
it'll automatically be able to detect
which is the better network and it'll
switch to that so if my 5g data is
faster than my wi-fi we're in business
so there's still a few features to come
that aren't actually in ios 15 yet like
the share play feature so you'll be able
to share music movies tv shows all of
those things i can't wait to try that
out and you can just do that right over
facetime another thing this is state by
state but digital identification in the
apple wallet i personally can't wait for
this because i know you guys have heard
the story already when i got my wallet
stolen lost my id and this wouldn't have
been a problem had it been digital
unless my phone got stolen then well
that's a whole nother story but the good
thing about that is everything is linked
to me personally with my apple icloud
account so even if i lost my phone
everything is always constantly being
backed up as long as you have that
setting turned on which i do recommend i
could go get another phone and i would
be able to recover all of my information
all of my data and i would have my
driver's license back i love the fact
that companies are working on things
like this do not disturb mode the focus
mode to kind of allow us to have a
better relationship with technology
setting limits setting times that you'll
be able to be notified and not
completely just inundated with
notification notification notification
after notification anyway i'll see you
guys in the next video i hope you guys
have a great day i'm working on trying
to figure out a better sign off
okay bye
[Music]
do you want to give me a line i'll give
you a couple okay you're you i'm justine
and we gotta go
you're you i'm i justine no i've gotta
go i'm just steaming
the video's over but the fun has just
begun the video is over but the fun has
just begun what is that word what fun is
there fun after this but the fun they
already had the fun the video's over
now you're not gonna have any more fun
peace that's good look at that peace
peace love and peace
[Music]